elle est présentée depuis ce matin par
tous les médias comme l'héroïne du rer b
sonia une jeune femme de 18 ans s'est
montré particulièrement courageuse en
empêchant un vol dans les transports en
commun un acte dans toutes les chaînes
en parler une vidéo qui elle aussi a
fait le tour des réseaux sociaux salué
par de très nombreux internautes heureux
que la mode soit enfin la solidarité
dans les transports en commun de moins
en moins sûre notamment pour les femmes
ce soir sonia est avec nous pour nous
raconter son geste alors ses
journalistes yoann fonds kitsch qui a
publié la vidéo sur twitter et en
seulement 24 heures à l'acte et vu
quatre millions de fois on va la revoir
la vidéo de sonia regard
match il va laisser les fans des gens
comme ça le torchis
voilà malheureusement pas les boules à
moi que vous avez l'habitude vous avez
vous je regarde en même temps même temps
tu veux ta main à mon épouse et moi je
suis fan
que tu dois se maquiller contre allée
dans le tranquille à la danse va mais
c'est ça non mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez incroyable
vous êtes dans les transports le 9
février vous repérez de deux personnes
au comportement bizarre et ensuite
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tout de suite
vous avez vu le dos alors les des
personnes et est assise en face de moi
est arrivé à la station saint-michel n 1
qui s'est levé en fait et c'est le
vétéran pense que moi que ma tête elle a
tourné en fait automatiquement et j'ai
eu le regard plongé genre la main dans
la poche de la dame
mais du coup par réflexe j'ai créé ma
dame et voilà et après c'est parti après
tués après c'est parce y est et pourquoi
tu as réagi comme ça sonne bien en fait
j'ai réagi comme ça t'a fallu tout en
instaurant pas du sujet non pas du tout
c'est fou où elle a un sens foi
incroyable dans la voix le contenu se
maquiller à parler aux mecs comme si de
rien n'était c'est dingue et c'est enfin
l'heure fois que tu fais ça où tu étais
ses amis enfin que ces films et ouais
ouais mais ça prend ça prend la fois que
je fais ça ou ça fait plus non ça
m'arrivait beaucoup de fois dans le dans
le métro sera ouais bah plusieurs
personnes à certaines stations dès que
les portes commence à sonner et dès que
les portes se ferment
bim sa cour et ça va racheter tout ce
qui bouge ton cul donc à chaque fois tu
interviens j'essaie d'intervenir leur
aspect clé brassard au bras
franchement alors il paraît que ça
t'énerve que donc prête pour une héroïne
tunis est de se tenir
alors je dis pas que ça m'énerve dès que
le mot héroïne il est sûrement il est
dispo repro so n'est dispo pour voir si
on est ici on trouve proportionnelle ok
disproportionnée votre mug pourquoi
parce que je pense que c'est un ce que
comment je réagirais adjiba normalement
je pense que c'est ainsi une attitude
que tout le monde doit adopter crier au
vol c'est pas quelque chose de wau bien
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui peuvent
être acquis doigts de fée de flipper qui
se dit oui c'est vrai
quand les maîtres les gens j'ai réagit
vraiment instinctivement à c'est ça
ouais t'as vu ça ça ta révolte et
utilise bien heureusement j à madame
voit la réplique à tom fait vraiment
parfait j'ai vu une scène comme ça une
fois dans le rer
une dame s'est interposé une dame de
monts agen qui avaient des enfants elle
s'est interposé s'est pris un coup de
cutter c'est çà de là jusque là les
enfants derrière ecsta donc c'est quand
je dis c'est courageux et assez héroïque
je fais et c'est pas disproportionnée je
pense que peut-être vous avez un
instinct comme ça de justice mais aussi
à l'instinct de survie parce que c'est
pour ce que j'ai vu c'était stabilité
aussi les moquer les mots qu'a choisi
sont très bons c'est des très bons mots
peu calmé tout de suite à paris si tu
fais tu lui parles on m'en donnait
d'ailleurs mais liège si tu parles un
mot d'arabe après il commence à te
répondre à l'accusation français
français et c'est génial
les intéristes ont fait tout de suite et
je voudrais moi je voudrais saluer son
quoi je m'attends voit plus en plus dans
le métro il ya des agressions les mecs
ne bouge pas
maintenant ça on gueule les mecs ils ont
peur ils sont dans leur coin ils se
tournent ils descendent du métro ils
vont dans l'autre à mémé tu as faim qui
sous le propos je ne peux pas cautionner
ça si tu as un mec qui te qui est en
train d'en mer des menaces il ya dix
mecs qui voit source mais j'ai pas
demandé de faire 2 1 contre 1 j'ai
demandé au maire de prendre le relief
est là et d'aller voir à cette fois pas
10 15 on y va y ont dit aux dégâts ce
genre de la ram et donc ça c'est pas
demandé s'annonce sur le papier c'est
facile tout le monde dont michel bah oui
sur le papier c'est facile mais aussi
bien des fois je me dis mais j'aimerais
bien intervenir mais franchement j'ai
peur ne supprime pas des films qu'on ait
vu le matin je me suis levé j'ai pris
une patate et les brasseries j'ai dit
oui
[Rires]
un jour raconté l'histoire d'une tasse
place clichy à mec il embrouille sa meuf
qui la pousse juin est judy arrête de la
poussée comme ça qui sut fait il dit
what scemama il m'a mis une patate là ma
femme engueuler quand tu passes tes
affaires
je me suis assise sociale si on prend
une patate assieds toi c'est pas des
affaires sociales m'engueuler mais j'ai
été quand même du prix une patate je me
tue à tignes c'est énorme
joyal emmène en dessous nationale b dans
le métro et bah si mais des personnes
qui ont fait bouger était intervenue et
bien effectivement je me suis pas
retrouvé la tête en sang donc j'ai
entièrement d'accord avec ray man ça
s'est désolé mais quelques choix
beaucoup mais c'est jésus nous avions
raconté l'anecdote wilsonien les avis
divergent parce que on peut se retrouver
avec des personnes qui auront le courage
de parler mais des personnes aussi
qu'ils vont pas oser soit ils sont
fatigués ils ont la flemme soit bailly
ils ont peur ils osent pas mais moi
avant même cette histoire là bas les
quoi deux jours avant il ya il ya un mec
dans le métro qui je montais les
escalators il est passé ma mine main aux
fesses et j'étais là en mode c'est
sérieux oui je me suis arrêté j'ai dit
est sérieux et il m'a dit j'ai fait quoi
avance et bayan monsieur ils étaient
tous elle
il est venu et s'est mis derrière moi il
a dit je fais avec elle mais
[Rires]
est ce que tu as vu des nouvelles de la
femme qui a failli se faire voler dans
le métro alors des nouvelles à la femme
non mais j'ai eu un message de son fils
il s'est perdu après sur les réseaux là
c'est sinon le parti tellement vite il
m'a envoyé un message et il m'a dit oui
merci beaucoup
l'ademe c'était ma mère en faisaient un
cool et j'ai vu j'ai dit oh moi si je
retrouve la personne qui a sauvé entre
guillemets ma mère serait grave à fond
ça m'a touché quand même bon et si tu
prends tous les journaux métro temple
inca ne crois pas que c'est cela reste
bien saisi alors vous avez décidé
d'enlever le mouvement hashtag pas sous
mes yeux vous inviter toutes les
personnes qui se sont fait agresser à
témoigner elle veut qu'il y ait un
réconfort général en tout cas merci
sonia
[Applaudissements]